- This episode of LegalEagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
Article Two, Section Two
of the Constitution states
that the president shall
be commander-in-chief
and he shall have power to
grant reprieves and pardons
for offenses against the United States,
except in cases of impeachment.
So under that language, can
the president pardon himself?
That's what we're going to find out today.
(magical music)
(gavel bangs)
Hey legal eagles, welcome
back to Lawsplainer,
where we explain the most
important legal concepts
of the day.
Don't forget to subscribe
and hit that bell
for more legal explanations,
and don't forget
to leave comment in the
form of an objection.
Today we're going to figure
out whether the president
has the power to pardon himself.
But first, let's talk
about what a pardon is.
A pardon is a action
bestowed on the president
by the Constitution of the United States
that completely sets aside
or commutes the punishment
for a crime.
A pardon is an admission of guilt.
To accept the pardon, the
recipient must essentially
admit that he committed
the underlying crime.
Now, a pardon only applies to, quote,
offenses against the United States,
in other words, federal crimes.
The president has no authority
to pardon state crimes.
One of the reasons that this
is particularly important now
is that President Trump
in a news conference
recently stated, "I have an absolute right
"to pardon myself."
- No, I'm not above the law.
I've never wanted anybody
to be above the law.
But the pardons are a very
positive thing for a president.
I think you see the way I'm using them.
And yes, I do have an absolute
right to pardon myself.
But I'll never have to do it,
because I didn't do anything wrong.
- He also tweeted, as has
been stated by numerous
legal scholars, I have the absolute right
to pardon myself, but why would I do that
when I have done nothing wrong?
In the meantime, the
never ending Witch Hunt,
led by 13 very Angry
and Conflicted Democrats
and others continues into the mid-terms.
So the question is, does
the president actually have
the power to pardon himself?
Well, as with most things
in constitutional law,
we should start with the
text of the Constitution.
Here, the text of the Constitution
provides a clear limit
on the president's pardon power.
The Pardon Clause provides
that the president
cannot pardon anyone in
cases of impeachment.
Now, there is an open
question as to whether
a sitting president can be
indicted or whether the only
remedy when a president
has committed some sort
of wrongdoing is impeachment.
In fact, I did a whole video on that.
There will be a link to that
down in the description.
If impeachment, however,
is the only remedy
when the president has committed a crime,
then it would make sense that
the impeachment exception
to the pardon power would
prevent the president
from pardoning himself.
And, if the president
cannot pardon himself,
because that necessarily
implicates an impeachment inquiry,
this principle could extend
to individuals whose actions
may be relevant to that
same impeachment inquiry.
For example, Paul Manafort or Mike Flynn
or other members of
President Trump's campaign
and staff have credible
allegations against them
that may implicate the
president, and therefore,
by necessity, that may
implicate impeachment,
which would prevent the
president from issuing
any kind of pardon as it regards himself
or as it regards the other
members of his cabinet.
But the impeachment
exception to the president's
pardon power has never been
tested, so it's an open question
whether that actually provides
a limit against the president
pardoning himself or not.
But on top of that, there
is also a general principle
in US law that a person
cannot be the judge
in their own case.
In fact, in 1974, when
President Nixon asked
the Office of Legal Counsel,
the OLC, to determine
if he could pardon himself, the
OLC relied on that principle
in saying that President Nixon
could not pardon himself.
In the famous August 5th, 1974, memo,
Mary Lawton, the Acting
Assistant Attorney General,
wrote, quote, under the fundamental rule
that no one may be the
judge in his own case,
the president cannot pardon himself.
Four days later, Nixon
resigned in disgrace.
So given that President Nixon's staff
opined that he could not pardon himself
and that even President
Nixon would not go so far,
as in issue a self-pardon,
that is potentially persuasive
authority that the president
doesn't have the power
to self-pardon.
Now, there's really only
one Supreme Court case
that's on point in this particular case,
and that is the Ex Parte
Garland Case from 1866.
This is a Supreme Court
case that often gets used
as an example of how
the president's ability
to pardon is basically unfettered,
but I think there's actually
a different principle
that is more important here.
The Ex Parte Garland Case
concerned Congress's ability
to exclude members of the Confederacy
from practicing federal
law after the Civil War,
and whether the president could pardon
a Confederate senator.
The Supreme Court held five to four
that the president could in fact pardon
the Confederate senator,
but more importantly,
the court held unanimously
that the Supreme Court
has the authority to interpret the scope
of the pardon power.
Like the bedrock Supreme
Court case of Marbury versus
Madison, Ex Parte Garland
is probably less important
for the actual outcome of
the case than the principle
that the Supreme Court
has the overview authority
to interpret the Constitution in this case
and make a decision one way or another.
In other words, it's less
important as to whether
the president has the
pardon power in question
than the fact that the
Supreme Court has the ability
to review the president's
pardons in the first place.
So if I was going to try to predict
what was going to happen
if a president ever tried
to pardon himself, the way things stands,
it appears that there is
nothing that would stop
the president from pardoning
himself in the first instance.
But under current Supreme Court case law,
the Supreme Court has the
power to review that pardon.
And if I had to guess what
the Supreme Court would do
with a self-pardon, I would
think that the Supreme Court
would actually nullify the
president's self-pardon
on the grounds that the
president cannot be the judge
in his own case or that the
impeachment exception applies,
which prevents the president's pardon
from going into effect.
Now, regardless of whether
the president actually
has the power to self-pardon,
it is almost universally
acknowledged that if a president ever did
try to pardon him or
herself, that it would almost
certainly lead to impeachment
by the House and Senate
and removal from office.
But that is not necessarily
required by the Constitution.
But frankly, I think I
speak for a lot of people
when I say that I hope
we never have to actually
test that legal principle in action.
Just to be on the safe
side, members of the current
administration might want to
brush up on their job skills,
just in case, like for example,
learning a new language, like Russian.
I'd recommend Alina
Sychova's Skillshare course
on basic Russian.
I hear there are many job opportunities
for senior campaign officials in Russia,
and it always helps to learn the language
of your employer.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 20,000
classes on everything,
like lifestyle, design, and technology
the first 500 legal eagles
will get two free months
of Skillshare when you
click on the link below.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited access
to must-know topics, so
you can improve your skills
and learn new things.
(speaking in foreign language)
So click on the link, get two free months,
and start learning today.
And until next time,
I'll see you in court.